qué es exactamente la flor ona y aunque
no es una enfermedad nueva deberíamos
preocuparnos en esta etapa de la
pandemia
buenas tardes básicamente es la
posibilidad de una coinfección es decir
que una persona al mismo tiempo voy a
tener la infección por los picos de la
influenza por el virus del sars cap 2 y
causante lakovic 19 en realidad es algo
que puede suceder y puede ser cuando los
dos virus están circulando porque
desafortunadamente el hecho que esté
infectado con un virus no me estime de
que me pueda del otro vídeo esto hace
que me diría que empieza a bajar la
circulación del sars todos y puede
circular el virus de influenza
desafortunadamente podríamos
contagiarnos de un nuevo el otro o como
en este caso de los dos de las voces
virus al mismo tiempo bueno ya aprovechó
para preguntarle qué tanto debe
alarmarnos esta nueva variante o micro
porque el número de contagios si es
mucho mayor que no las anteriores pero
no es igual en la tasa de mortalidad que
no crece al mismo ritmo hay quienes
dicen que esta pandemia ya se está
incluso convirtiendo en endemia como
podríamos explicar todo este fenómeno
mira yo creo que hay dos puntos
importantes esta variante
definitivamente es una variante que es
más contagiosa y por eso la rápida un
rápido incremento de casos entre los
países que está circulando esto se da
porque el virus y tiene esa capacidad de
infectar más personas y al parecer
pareciera que no afecta tanto los
pulmones y por esto es menos agresivo
menos virulenta sin embargo no hay que
engañarnos en el sentido en que también
hay que tener en cuenta que hay una
variable adicional y es que muchas
personas están vacunadas también hay que
decir que hay personas que se han
actuado y por ende infectarse y
definitivamente lo que sí sabemos es que
las personas que no se han vacunado
cuando se contagian de la variante o
mika tienen más riesgo es mentalizarse y
también que complicarse